ask yourself this question are you
someone who relies on motivation or
discipline to get things done maybe you
don't know the answer to that question
or maybe your answer is well a little
bit of both well in this video I'm going
to talk about why discipline is
infinitely more powerful than motivation
and why you should never rely on
motivation ever again to get things done
I'm Joey and welcome to better ideas
[Music]
so I said I was gonna tell you why you
should never rely on motivation ever
again to get things done but don't
interpret that as me saying that
motivation is a bad thing
motivation is great and it should be
taken full advantage of but what are you
supposed to do on days where you're just
not motivated at all the days where
you've forgotten all your original goals
all the reasons why you're excited about
improving in the first place and days
where you just don't really want to do
anything you see motivation is great but
it's fleeting it comes and goes
think about it as a divine gift from
above you know you're blessed with it
every once in a while it gives you a
little kick in the pants gets you moving
makes you inspired set new goals dream
big sometimes this motivation can last
days weeks months but you'll always hit
a roadblock you'll have an off day an
off week the stress of schoolwork
relationships start piling up and you're
just not as motivated as you were before
you're in a situation where you need
motivation the most but it's not there
for you motivation has failed you
thankfully there's hope and it's called
discipline and discipline operates
differently than motivation whereas
motivation is a divinely inspired gift
from above discipline is a muscle a
mechanical neurological system that
gains power and influence through
repetition a lot of people think about
discipline like it's something that some
people have and some people don't you
know I'm not a very disciplined kind of
guy or I just kind of go with the flow
and I wait till I'm motivated to do
stuff but discipline isn't a character
trait it's a tool that everyone has just
not everyone uses truth is everyone has
enough discipline to do at least one
thing every single day towards a larger
goal the folks over on reddit call this
having a non zero day a non zero day is
a day where you do at least one thing
towards a larger goal instead of doing
nothing for instance a zero day sounds
like this man last Saturday I was so
lazy oh so tired I really didn't feel
like doing anything I just played xbox
all day long a something day sounds like
this man last Saturday I was so lazy so
tired I didn't feel like doing anything
I pretty much played xbox the entire day
but my larger goal my bigger goal is to
get fit so I promised myself I would
walk at least once around the block
obviously overall that sounds like a
lazy day no matter what but the
difference between doing something and
not doing something
as I've talked about in a previous video
the slight edge the compound effect
whatever you want to call it the subtle
difference but it's a huge difference
and it's extremely important to do that
little thing towards a larger goal every
single day because it's better than zero
so set some goals some really big goals
life goals and convert it into a little
tiny action that you can do every single
day and stick with it for a month
because after a month it'll become a
habit and habits have momentum pretty
soon that habit will become just a
well-oiled machine that's ingrained into
your daily lifestyle and eventually that
healthy thing will become easier to do
than it is not to do because it's a
habit like chewing your nails or picking
your nose except it's actually really
good for you and it's making you better
every single day without you having to
think about it if you like this video
and want to see me make more be sure to
hit that subscribe button down below
also leave a comment if you want to give
me some constructive criticism or if you
just want to make a comment about
anything in general like my ugly face or
my awesome background for more
information on building discipline and
habits in general a great and
award-winning book I don't know if it's
award-winning I just made that up a
highly reviewed book is the power of
habit by Charles Duhigg I'll put a link
in the description for that book thanks
a lot for watching and we'll catch you
in the next video